[Musique]
mon invité a la réputation d'être une
machine de guerre lors des campagnes
électorales à la fois stratège
négociateur et organisateur hors pa
autant de qualité qu'il faut peut-être
mettre en rapport avec son cursus
universitaire puisqu'il est docteur en
mathématiques
appliqué bonjour manuel bonpard bonjour
Alors on s'engage en politique avant
tout pour défendre des idées mais quand
on regarde votre parcours il est
tellement lié à la personne de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon que je me demande est-ce que
vous vous seriez engagé en politique
sans lui euh sans doute mais c'est vrai
que j'ai trouvé à ce moment-là une
personnalité qui défendait les
convictions qui étaient les miennes
j'étais intéressé par la politique
depuis depuis que j'étais j'étais jeune
révolté je pense aussi face à la marche
du monde aux inégalités sociales mais
j'avais une difficulté c'est que je me
retrouvais ni dans le Parti socialiste
tel qu'il était où je considérais qu'il
avait abandonné on va dire une certaine
perspective de transformation de la
société ni dans les autres parties à la
gauche du parti Parti socialiste don
j'avais l'impression que il se posait
pas la question de la stratégie de la
conquête du pouvoir et c'est vrai que
dans les écrits dans les interventions
dans la démarche politique de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon j'ai trouvé ce qui de mon
point de vue était à la fois une
perspective de transformation de la
société et en même temps une volonté de
prendre le pouvoir et de changer
réellement la vie des gens et donc vous
vous êtes engagé dans le Parti de Gauche
dès sa création par par Jean-Luc
Mélenchon en
2008 à l'époque vous étiez un jeune
ingénieur docteur en mathématiques
appliqué j'ai lu que il s'est un peu upé
de votre formation intellectuelle qui
vous a fait lire des des bouquins c'est
vrai c'est vrai ouais c'est-à-dire que
quels auteurs c'était B les les les
classiques du matérialisme historique
Marx les classiques de de de du du du
socialisme Jean jores c'est vrai que moi
j'avais une formation très scientifique
en vérité je me rappelle que le premier
livre qui m'a conseillé c'était
socialisme utopique socialisme
scientifique un livre de Marx et Engels
et c'est vrai que dans un univers très
très éloigné de de votre parcours
universitaire voilà et et c'est vrai que
ça m'a ça m'a accroché donc après je
j'ai j'ai continuer et alors donc il
s'est il s'est occupé de votre formation
intellectuelle j'ai vu qu'il vous a
aussi hébergé chez lui quand vous deviez
encore faire des allers-retours entre
Toulouse et Paris vous aviez pas de pied
à terre ensuite bah il vous a quand même
confié la direction de ses deux
campagnes présidentielles 2017-2022 en
2022 il vous a transmis en quelque sorte
sa circonscription à à Marseille il vous
a confié les reennes du mouvement la
France insoumise on sent qu'il y a une
confiance absolue et réciproque et une
compréhension mutuelle entre vous euh
vous évoquez même une relation télé
avec lui non ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que c'est vrai quand ça fait
depuis plusieurs années qu'on travaille
ensemble on a compris un peu comment
l'autre personne fonctionne comment elle
réagit aux événements et c'est vrai que
parfois il y a pas forcément besoin de
se parler pour avoir une réaction sur
des faits d'actualité ou sur des
éléments stratégiques qui est un peu la
même vous vous vous comprenez
parfaitement alors vous avez des
personnalités très différentes lui c'est
un pur littéraire il peut avoir des gros
coups de sang vous êtes un pur
scientifique et vous êtes plutôt la
réputation d'avoir du sang froid c'est
c'est quoi c'est la complément mentarité
qui fait que peut-être en tout cas c'est
des habitudes de travail et le sentiment
que ça a bien fonctionné donc c'est vrai
qu'on a pas forcément le même caractère
mais je pense qu'on travaill plutôt bien
ensemble alors vous avez obtenu des
résultats assez impressionnants en tant
que directeur de de ces campagnes
présidentielles à lui mais la première
grande campagne que vous avez mené en
votre nom propre vous l'avez perdu en
2017 au législative à Toulouse c'est
c'est plus compliqué d'être en en
première ligne c'est euh c'est toujours
plus compliqué d'être en première ligne
parce que ça ça ça nécessite pas
forcément les mêmes savoir-faire les
même qualité que d'être directeur de
campagne aller aller sur le terrain àors
r fait peur moi j'étais d'abord avant
d'être directeur de campagne j'étais
d'abord militant comme beaucoup de
gensrond votre nature oui oui j'ai pas
de difficulté avec ça après honnêtement
en 2017 aux élections législatif vous
savez les la France à soumise elle a eu
seulement 17 députés je crois pouvoir
dire aussi que les le contexte national
était plus compliqué et donc c'est vrai
que sur la circonscription sur laquelle
j'étais candidat à Toulouse j'ai été
qualifié au second tour mais j'ai pas
réussi à à à l'emporter au au deuxème
tour bon ben on a corrigé ça la fois
d'après alors j'ai jeté un œil à à votre
thèse Modèle de substitution pour
l'optimisation globale de forme en
aérodynamique et méthode local sans
paramétrisation donc j'ai a rien compris
sauf que vous êtes un pur scientifique
eu il y en a pas beaucoup en politique
est-ce que les scientifiques ont une
façon d'aborder la politique qui leur
est propre en tout cas je pense que ça
on a des des des qualités des qui des
réflexes qui de mon point de vue sont
utiles dans la bataille politique c'est
quoi quelle qualité quelle une certaine
capacité de rigueur une certaine
capacité à lire les événements avec on
va dire un sens de la logique donc en
terme de de de réflexion stratégique ou
de réflexion politique je trouve que ça
peut ça peut ça peut aider au sein des
LFI vous êtes un peu le le Goo alors pas
forcément le gentil organisateur au sens
du club M plutôt le grand ordinateur je
dis ça parce que vous êtes à la fois le
stratège le cerveau et puis celui qui
fait tourner la boutique LFI tous les
jours et à chaque fois vous avez un
souci permanent d'efficacité partout
vous êtes là pour chasser un peu les
grains de sable qui peuvent enrayer la
la mécanique on a l'impression que chez
vous l'efficacité c'est le préalable à
tout en politique moi je me suis engagé
en politique avec l'objectif de faire en
sorte que les idées qui sont les miennes
et les idées qu'on défend arrivent au
pouvoir prennent le pouvoir et soient
appliqué et c'est vrai que dans mon
parcours en tout cas j'ai toujours pas
refuser si vous voulez d'être uniquement
dans une logique de de de protestation
et donc c'est peut-être ça qui qui qui
qui vous fait poser cette cette cette
question donc l'efficacité oui je pense
que c'est c'est l'efficacité dans tous
les domaines ça peut être vérifier qu'il
y a bien un deuxième micro dans un
meeting pour être sûr que si le premier
tombe en P c'est vrai ben écoutez moi
j'ai toujours considéré que quand on
veut prendre le pouvoir dans un pays qui
est la 5e ou 6e puissance économique du
monde il valait mieux le faire
sérieusement parce que sinon on n'était
pas crédible et donc je pense que dans
une campagne présidentielle une campagne
présidentielle c'est une grosse machine
et à n'importe quel moment dans cette
grosse machine il y a un petit grain de
sable qui peut faire dérailler la la
campagne donc j'ai toujours eu et ça je
pense je suis pas le seul he je pense
c'est une culture politique assez forte
à la France insoumise une attention pour
ce qui peut être de l'ordre du détail
mais qui en vérité n n'en est pas alors
c'est au nom de l'efficacité que vous
avez réorganisé la direction de la
France insoumise sans faire valider les
nominations par un vote certains anciens
du mouvement qui ont été écartés s'en
sont plein et là vous leur avez répondu
le vote n'est pas forcément l'alpha et
l'oméga de la démocratie l'objectif
c'est d'être le plus efficace possible
comment est-ce que vous auriez réagit si
Elizabeth borne avait utilisé la même
phrase pour justifier le 493 sur les
retraites écoutez je pense d'abord que
cette phrase elle a été totalement
sortie de son contexte je vous dis je
disais que dans une organisation
politique il faut des modalités de
délibération collective que parfois ça
peut être un vote et que parfois il peut
y avoir d'autres modalités de
délibération collective et par exemple à
la France à soumise on essaie
d'expérimenter c'est pas toujours facile
le fait que plutôt de se poser en
permanence la question d'un clivage
entre une majorité et une minorité on
essaie de fonctionner plutôt avec des
processus de décision par consensus des
processus de décision ou petit à petit
en échangeant les uns les autres vous
êtes contre les courants au sein de la
France comme il a pu en avoir au PS oui
parce que je pense que ça ça ça ça
produit pas quelque chose de bon parce
que ça produit une situation dans
lequelle en vérité on passe l'essentiel
de notre temps à nous disputer en
interne des organisations politiques
plutôt qu'à consacrer notre énergie à la
transformation de la de la société mais
parfois on n'est pas d'accord et donc
parfois il faut voter bien évidemment
j'ai jamais dit que j'étais opposé
opposé au vote mais je pense qu'il y a
d'autres manières pour faire en sorte
qu'on se pose pas toujours la question
de regarder d'abord qu'est-ce qui nous
divise ou qu'est-ce qui nous sépare mais
plutôt qu'est-ce qui peut nous regrouper
et nous rassembler voilà pourquoi j'ai
dit cette phrase bien évidemment il n'y
a aucune analogie possible avec le
fonctionnement d'un pays ou avec le
fonctionnement d'une Assemblée nationale
dans lequel les députés ils ont été élus
pour voter et donc moi je souhaite que
les députés ils puissent voter bien
évidemment alors c'est un peu le pendant
de votre souci d'efficacité vous avez
aussi une réputation de Bad Cop qui vous
colle à la peau euh je regardais
l'ebdomadaire Marianne le portrait qui
vous a consacré il vous a surnommé le
nettoyeur de Mélenchon sur ce thème on
retrouve beaucoup de qualificatifs qui
sont toujours glissés en off et qui sont
jamais très sympathiques pour vous j'ai
relevé flingueur je vous le confirme
liquidateur tueur à gage ça vous agace
tout ça c'est c'est pas que ça m'agace
ça fait sans doute partie de la vie
politique malheureusement d'être parfois
fublé de qualificatif qui de mon point
de vue correspondent pas à la personne
que je suis parce vous avez quand même
pour mission de de faire tourner un peu
le la maison mais vous savez quand vous
faites tourner une machine politique une
organisation politique euh vous avez
toujours sans doute des décisions avec
lequel il y a des gens qui se retrouvent
pas dans ces décisions ça arrive moi
j'essaie toujours de le faire plutôt
dans le respect de chacune et de chacun
donc je me retrouve bien évidemment pas
dans ces qualificatif mais franchement
ça m'empêche pas de dormir parce que si
ça ça m'empêchait de dormir
malheureusement je dormiraiis pas
beaucoup alors dans vos multiples
missions vous avez été l'un des artisans
de euh l'un des principaux artisans de
la nup c'est d'ailleurs vous qui avez
annoncé l'accord à avec les écologistes
on va revoir ça en
image minuit 5 après des heures de
tractation et sous le regard de Jean-Luc
Mélanchon dernière politesse de rigueur
et satisfaction partagé Vy commence
commence commence en quelques jours en
quelques dizaines d'heur on a réussi ce
qui avait été impossible pendant
plusieurs années je crois que c'est
historique en tout cas nos formations
politiques n'avaent pas fait d'accord
aux élections législatives c'est la
première fois que ça arrive alors cet
accord entre tous les partis gauche il y
avait pas grand monde qui croyait au
début Jean-Luc Mélenchon en AR rêé et
c'est vous en quelque sorte qui l'avez
fait est-ce que pour vous ça reste l'un
de vos plus grands accomplissements
politiques à ce jour ah c'était un
moment qui était un moment historique
c'est clair c'est un c'est un accord qui
restera dans l'histoire peu de gens y
croyaient ça nous a demandé beaucoup de
travail ça nous a demandé d'apprendre à
se connaître aussi parce qu'on se
connaissait pas forcément ça nous a
demandé de faire des compromis parce que
quand on fait un accord on fait des
compromis et d'engager des rapports de
force vous assumez clairement auss Rapp
des moments où vous pouvez être très dur
écoutez moi je crois à la franchise en
politique et je peux faire semblant ou
je peux faire semblant je pourrais faire
semblant qu'en politique il n'existe pas
de rapport de force mais il y a bien
évidemment des rapports de force qui a
permis la constitution de cet accord
c'est notamment le fait que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon ait fait 22 % des voix à
l'élection présidentielle mais le
rapport de force ça n'enlève pas ou ça
n'empêche pas le respect pour ses
partenaires et moi j'ai toujours coutume
de dire que dans une négociation entre
différentes formations politiques c'est
une bonne négociation si à la fin tout
le monde a l'impression d'avoir gagné
tout le monde a le sentiment d'avoir
gagné personne n eu le sentiment de
s'être senti humilié donc voilà je pense
que ce qui a fonctionné dans cet accord
c'est que tout le monde à la fin a fait
des pas mais tout le monde s'est reconnu
et s'est retrouvé dans un accord qui
était productif qui était efficace parce
que je rappelle que grâce à cet accord
nous avons remporté le premier tour des
élections législatives nous avons fini
en tête du premier tour des élections
législatives et nous avons permis
d'avoir 151 députés à l'Assemblée
nationale donc voilà je pense que
c'était un moment historique c'est clair
que ça restera pour moi un moment
important de ma vie politique on va
passer à notre quiz à présent alors avec
vous j'ai eu envie de faire un vrai faux
pour vérifier certaines choses que j'ai
lu sur vous et qui m'ont étonné on
commence est-il vrai que quand vous
ennuyez dans une réunion vous vous
détendez en résolvant des équations non
c'est faux j'ai lu ça aussi ça a pu
m'arver tellement tellement mais je fais
pas d'équations sur mes sur mon temps
personnel et R je m'ennuie rarement en
réunion d'ailleurs parce que je pense
que souvent les discussions sont
intéressantes et productives il paraît
qu'adolescent vous classiez les disques
de vos rappeurs préférés par leur ville
d'origine c'est vrai c'est vrai ouais
c'est vrai j'avais c'est bizarre comme
méthode de classement oui mais je sais
pas pourquoi j'avais j'avais besoin de
d'avoir des cases dans lequel je pouvais
mettre tous mes disques c'est vrai c'est
vrai que je faisais ça avec plus de
rappeur du côté de Marseille oui pas mal
ouais c'est vrai que moi j'étais plutôt
c'est vrai j'ai vraiment j'ai grandi moi
dans la génération
AAM donc c'est vrai que j'ai j'ai
j'avais un tropisme marseillais on va
dire dans mes goûs musicaux enfin j'ai
lu que pendant plusieurs années vous
avez été goûteur de Morito au stand du
Parti de Gauche de la Fête de l'Huma ah
c'est pas totalement faux mais un peu
extrapolé il se trouve que dans les
premiers stands du Parti de Gauche à la
Fête de l'Humanité effectivement on
avait il y avait une buvette avec du
Morito pour les gens qui venaient à sur
le stand et B oui forcément quand on
avait préparé la recette il fallait
vérifier que la recette était bonne
avant de vendre donc ça c'était vous qui
prépariez les les premièrees fois oui
c'est pour ça je vous disais moi j'ai
j'ai j'ai j'ai vraiment eu d'abord un
engagement militant je distribué des
tracks je participé à l'organisation du
stand à la Fête de l'Humanité j'organis
a image de de celle qu'on peut avoir de
vous peut-être plus fétard que que vous
pouvez donner l'impression euh fétard
oui enfin en tout
cas j'aime bien comme plein de gens je
penseent passer des bons moments et pas
uniquement faire de la politique qui
peut avoir un côté parfois un petit peu
froid mais maintenant je je je dois être
un peu plus sérieux du fait des
responsabilités qui sont les miennes ça
empêche pas de continuer à garder
parfois des moments où on peut se
détendre et s'amuser mais avec un grand
sens des responsabilités et ben ce sera
le mod fin merci beaucoup Bard d'être
venu dans la politique et
moi